moment of silence please for what may be
the most tragic casualty of the season
of Game of Thrones and that is the
characterization of Brienne of Tarth
[Applause]
[Music]
Game of Thrones season 8 episode 4 look
there are some things that Game of
Thrones consistently did well at least
for a while they almost always do well
and that they never do well Game of
Thrones used to they seem to have lost a
talent for it but for a while they were
very good at building up towards
something you weren't always sure what
but honestly those like the first four
seasons were just build up and it was
expertly laid build up what they are
usually good at is spectacle when they
decide that the build up is actually
going to result in a thing you know
whether that be a one-on-one fight like
the mountain versus the Viper or if it's
gonna be large-scale some of the ideas
the assault on the wall or what have you
what at least to my taste they have
never been good at is the lull after the
big thing and which is a shame because
you kind of need the lull after the big
thing at least a slight one otherwise it
just becomes relentless but they really
kind of suck at it this episode was
really hard for me and I think this is
the episode that I've had the hardest
time getting through and that I groaned
at the most since the bear and the
maiden fair which is my least favorite
episode of the show so for folks who
weren't watching me what's ten years ago
or whatever and don't feel like going
back to when I you know the camera was
crap and I didn't know what I was doing
my issue with the Baron the maid in
favors they basically took every subplot
I didn't care about ie every
romantically tinged subplot and crammed
it all into one single episode which did
mean that basically all those plot lines
weren't stinking up everything else but
it did make that one episode absolutely
insufferable it basically treated it as
ripping off a band-aid but man that
band-aid frickin hurt and I get a very
similar vibe from this not that the
romantic stuff is the only thing going
on here but basically everything that
was going on here was stuff that I
either didn't care about don't like or
send it on characters who I don't really
enjoy anymore there are a handful of
decent moments ah bran thank god bran
showed up halfway through this thing and
live in the thing up
I love bran he's great I love that he's
just standing there or the Cross was
saying I'm not fighting in this battle
for you but you're gonna give me stuff
for not killing you and you better hunt
you better own up to it cuz I'm not I
may not be in the war anymore but I'm
not above killing people and like he was
great he was great I loved bran torment
was fun ridiculous giant man he was fun
seeing Arya and the Hound together again
that was nice but these are all tiny
flitting moments and almost everything
else made me freaking cringe where do we
even start I'm probably not even gonna
remember all of it at this point my
brains already trying to expunge it from
my head so huh Daenerys look I do not
want her on the throne at this point she
has been such an inconsistent character
in terms of whether or not she's
supposed to be depicted as a good leader
or not like I get that they've been
trying to go for this balance if she
wants to be a liberator but she has like
tyrannical instincts they haven't been
balancing that though they just have her
flip back and forth depending on the
story of whatever episode is given and
they're pushing her back towards
tyrannical ruler again so we've got that
going on and the whole thing between her
and John I still don't like it like
first of all I still don't by the degree
of the romantic connection so the idea
that either one of them is even vaguely
considering
you know throwing things away in order
to accommodate each other I'm like nope
conversation between tyrion and varys
that was decent it was nice to see some
people talking rationally about this
Sansa had some decent moments Sansa
Sansa and the Hound that was a good
moment I like that the Hound says you
know if you'd come with me you never
would have gone through all this stuff
and she said well if I hadn't gone
through all that I'd still be that same
little bird and I like the
acknowledgement that for all the crap
that she has been through it is what has
made her who she is and while she
doesn't automatically paint that as like
and therefore it's okay
it is nice to see an acknowledgment that
look I survived and something came of
that so cool that was a decent moment
the whole thing with your on taking down
another Dragon Age I know I know that
they were going for like the sudden hmm
kind of death with the dragon but like I
didn't care like look we've already lost
that we had the surprise of losing a
dragon last season for the first time so
the novelty of just losing a dragon is
kind of gone and I'm sorry the dragons
aren't characters they're props that
like the I would I was always way more
invested in the direwolves than I was in
the Dragons and also leaving ghosts
behind that was dumb it was really dumb
like okay I get the explanation like oh
it belongs to north fine but direwolf
yep okay so let's get on to more of the
romantic stuff so I get why it happens
you know Gendry does his whole I'm a
lord now you know with aria and he gets
down on one knee and like I like arias
reaction to it but I hate the scenario
and I hit the situation and Genji looked
like a friggin [ __ ] I do like that
Aria has a callback to her very first
episode like I'm not a lady That's not
me
good glad she remembered who she was
cuz bran didn't look I know that the
tension romantic sexual whatever the
hell
tension between her and Jamie has been a
thing for a while but I didn't buy it
back in the bay the bear and the maiden
fair I kind of worked with it a little
bit like when it sort of came up a
little bit later but that that felt more
like ambiguous between romantic
interests and camaraderie from having
traveled together but now it's
unambiguously romantic again and I don't
like it I don't care oh let's take this
Garrett to has been absolutely defined
by her sense of duty and her desire to
to serve a greater good and have her
break down in tears oh because I because
a guy decided to sleep with her which
has never happened before she's a very
odd and I also don't look like this
isnow to virginity losses in a row two
episodes in a row and look people didn't
seem to get my issue with Ariana so I'm
not gonna try and explain it again cuz I
don't know how to other than I just
didn't like it but this like it
completely redefines what is important
to this character and it's wrong it's
wrong I'm sorry it's wrong so just look
I'm probably reacting to this more
harshly than other people do because I
don't like romantic subplot 95% of the
time and I never really saw a bit like
again the general bonding between Jamie
and Brianna fine you want to hit it at
that kind of chemistry like okay but
when you make it actually motivate their
direct actions no no I don't want it I
don't like it I kind of freak no I don't
kind of I hate it I hate it
it's her and here's the thing and I I
mentioned this and I'll mention it here
now because maybe it'll help people get
it the problem is the pattern not every
instance sometimes these sorts of things
can work my problem is it is such a
default for basically every single story
especially on a TV show where characters
are put together and you get actor
chemistry going on that ain't
there is a male and a female character
put in isolation for a long enough
stretch of time that they fall in love
with each other and I just am sick of it
at this way I don't care if you do it
well which I would argue this doesn't
but even if it did I still wouldn't like
it because I'm sick of that you served
me the same dish day after day after day
I'm gonna be sick of it even if you
present me with this is the most
masterfully cooked this dish will ever
be I don't care I'm sick of it I never
came to this show for romantic subplots
the about the only one that I cared
about at all was jaime and cersei and
that's not because like I wanted them
together whose because it drove
interesting plot like right off the bat
he pushed the kid out of window because
of that I'm like okay cool so it's not
like I was invested in wanted them to
succeed but that was a romantic
entanglement that actually drove the
plot in an interesting and unexpected
way as opposed to oh these two people
care for each other you know exactly
where that's going but the only other
time that word from me eventually was
with Ygritte now initially when a
Gretton and Jon Snow hook up hailey
again bear in the maiden fair god do i
hate that episode so they end with them
kissing on that like oh god I hated it
so much but then he turns his back on
her and she shoots arrows into his back
good
that was awesome and that was amazing
and I needed that catharsis to cleanse
me of the crap of these stupid friggin I
don't like when romantic subplots inject
themselves and demand screen time and
start causing characters to behave in
ways inconsistent with the how they used
to behave previously and a show that is
not about that I hate it in Game of
Thrones I hated it wherever I see it I
hate it in movies I headed in TV I hated
in books I hid it in comics I hate how
romance makes people dumb I'm really
really really really sick of it and
yeah that'll do it whatever the heck
this episode was called I can't even
remember you seen it what did you think
about it you probably not as ticked off
as I am I'm sure most people aren't I'm
probably the only one who gets annoyed
by this but whatever your thoughts are
dropping down on the comments let's talk
about it other stuff to do down there
patreon really really appreciated plus
I'll be links to check out there's merch
there's things to do click on links and
check them out or don't you don't have
to I'm not gonna force you to deal with
it like you shows like this force us to
deal with romantic entanglements because
at the end of the day I understand that
you are the council and I'm only running
the meetings so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]